los científicos están en una carrera
contrarreloj intentando determinar la
peligrosidad de la nueva variante del
virus de covite 19 descubierta primero
en sudáfrica la variante omicron ha
demostrado extenderse muy rápidamente
esto ha llevado a gobiernos de varias
partes del mundo a de nuevo imponer
restricciones de viaje como un esfuerzo
de contener la expansión la organización
mundial de la salud ya ha clasificado a
omicron como una variante de
preocupación
widget know whether omicron is a sos aún
no sabemos si o micro me está asociado
con una mayor transmisión una mayor
enfermedad mayor riesgo de infección o
mayor riesgo para evadir las vacunas
vaccines
santis los científicos de la oms
alrededor del mundo están trabajando con
urgencia para responder a estas
preguntas this questions la comunidad
científica está muy preocupada por las
más de 30 mutaciones que presenta la
proteína de espiga de esta variante del
virus que podría inferir en qué tan
contagiosa es y en su capacidad para
evadir las defensas del organismo
otro elemento desconocido es que tan
enferma puede llegar a estar la gente
por la nueva variante algunos médicos
han reportado síntomas leves mientras
otros aseguran que han visto casos
graves en los hospitales sudafricanos
los científicos afirman que habrá que
esperar al menos dos semanas antes de
tener más información concreta sobre la
variante omicron mientras tanto las
farmacéuticas ya están trabajando en
nuevas fórmulas para sus vacunas
mientras aumenta la atención para las
autoridades sanitarias la mejor
protección sigue siendo la vacunación
llevar mascarilla y respetar el
distanciamiento social